that's if the mom's not a good mother
irrespective
what what what what famous baby daddies
didn't do better than their first baby
mama because i'm thinking of like all
the guys with a bunch of kids like nick
cannon future they're all dating
a new hot 22.
yeah i think i think just because of
your age doesn't mean you're a better
woman
just because it well to them it does
that's what i value because men value
fertility i'm pretty certain will smith
could do way better
yeah but she's a mad babe that's
different
she's like a five to be honest she's
like absolutely she's just babe jada
pinkett is average looking yeah she's
average she was hot when she was yeah
she is yeah but like she's like 45 50.
and she's you think at her age she's
still average looking she looks good for
her age but like if you asked a guy
would he prefer a 25 year old version of
her i think most would prefer the 25
year old version yeah that would i think
that's for anyone though so now she's 45
there aren't men lined up to date 45
year old let's say she's average i feel
i don't think she's average i think i
think you have to
um assess everything in its category i
think for her age she's definitely not
about it well the things that men value
are fertility right femininity and youth
she doesn't have youth clearly
she doesn't have youth she's clearly not
feminine and she's not fertile you also
missed one pearl loyalty yeah
you're right
i i have to agree with the um
you can find a better baby mother
because i think there's more good women
than there are good men
so yeah i could agree with that there
are more good women than there are good
men yeah what what makes you say that
and what's your statistical data on that
and what is the version it's not it's
just my opinion it's not statistics is
it is it because of the men you deal
with
um no i'm married so it's not the men i
deal with i'm just curious what like why
is that your opinion on man
um because it's just my opinion i think
there are well for one there's more
women in the world so you're probably
going to find more good women than you
are going to find good men so that's
just it it's like 50 it's it's pretty
close it's like 55 45 yeah i'm sorry i'm
dealing with statistic people sorry
i
you encountered more
good women than men but i don't think i
would i wouldn't say that there's more
good women than men
honestly modern women today by like what
men value it's not like i would say
they're worse than men yeah because the
average age of first marriage is 31 in
the uk so you're taking away the youth
and the fertility
and then um they also value purity so
they're older they're clearly going to
have slept with more people
um
interesting
i think as well the fact that you're
married
how long have you been with your partner
for
in in total yeah 16 years 16 years so
first of all you haven't been single for
a while and been in the single game it's
a lot's changed since then okay
and i also think that married women just
generally hang around with better people
in general single women will hang around
with other single women degenerate some
some of them you say degenerate some of
them are degenerate wow
i just don't think that married women
will hang around with a load of single
degenerate so can i can i ask so just a
question are all married women
better than single women
in my opinion i i in my opinion i see
them as more high values no i think you
have more respect for them doesn't mean
that yeah i think you have more respect
because of their status they're not
necessarily better women women yeah
yeah that's a good question
yeah so what's what are we using as
better what's the use i mean like i
think i think they got picked right so i
think when someone has a ring on their
finger like other men acknowledge that
another man vetted her and picked her so
it doesn't necessarily mean every single
one but in by and large in general like
men know how to pick women and vet women
i mean technically jada pink smith is a
married woman yeah i don't really
respect her so exactly so our women out
here just you know because for me as a
man
um when i see who you've had a child
with that says some things to me okay i
agree i agree so i'm gonna look at who
you've bred with who you've chosen to
breed with and if and if i'm thinking of
stepping into that situation what would
be the ramifications for me stepping
into that situation i agree right so
um a lot of women complain about their
quote unquote baby daddies whereas they
are the ones that chose their baby daddy
so as a man i'm looking at you first of
all maybe you don't know how to choose
men and maybe you're bad at choosing and
then so
when a lot of women complain about their
baby fathers it's like well you're
actually complaining about the choice
that you actually made agree mm-hmm
fair point i think i think with
experience
comes like wisdom and i feel like when i
chose my baby father personally
it was i was in a certain mind frame i
was a lot younger i was in a different i
was going through different things and i
think the experience of my baby father
lets me know what i don't want what did
you choose about your baby father
he was a god-fearing person he was a
kind he is a kind person and he is
god-fearing and he's a very very hard
worker again it was just we couldn't
make things so he's a good man yeah he's
a good man speaking to the mic so
if he's a good man why why are you not
with him because he's not good for me
why is he not good for you being a good
man doesn't necessarily mean you and i
are compatible why why is he not good
for you but he have
but it was compatible enough to have a
child with he was compatible enough for
me to be sexually attracted to him
that's how you make a child
right yeah but right but
but
the choice to have the child is yours
yeah it's not his right no right so i'm
saying that you chose to i chose my
child because i wanted to have my child
yeah yeah i'm saying but you chose it
with him so if he's a i'm just asking
that because i'm just trying to work out
well complicated
it's interesting wouldn't it be within
the best interests for the childhood
like for you to work that out you too
my child's
going to be happy regardless as long as
she has her mom and she as long as she
has her dad doesn't necessarily mean us
together
will give her in happy environment
you put your kid at every statistical
advantage or disadvantage when you don't
have two parents in the home so like
statistically they're more likely to go
to jail they're more likely to fail out
of school if my daughter doesn't follow
statistics she follows the path of god
so
that sounds fantastic but the statistics
don't care about that so can i just ask
but isn't it like like
under the path of god it's like till
death to you part i didn't get my reach
yeah you had a kid that's like a step
after which also doesn't follow in line
with like yeah and i deal with it okay
and it's my close to cassie sorry can i
just ask do you guys use statistics on
your day-to-day life or is it just
um if yeah if you're having like if
you're trying to have like a
conversation or debate about it okay
okay yeah that's fine you know yeah
if if it's debates then it's fine but if
i'm just curious if you guys use it on
yeah i mean i mean like i said though
like pearl was saying like
you put your child at like a
disadvantage if you choose not to have
that child within a family unit right
okay and i mean even specifically um
within like within america i think it's
like 72 percent of even black households
are raised by like a single mum yeah and
then you can you can look at there's a
single parent
to prison pipeline there's that you can
see it you can see that most people in
prison come from
single-parent homes
so yeah i was going to say in addition
to that as well
not only
are the kind of the single-parent
households
like levels high in the u.s but what
that does as well is that actually it
actually like puts us like below the
poverty line so in regards from a
demographic perspective we have the
poorest household households a single
parent just because of the fact that
there's there's not there's not two
earners in the household so i'll just
say that here that both of us definitely
earned them more than some two-hold
two-parent households so that's why for
me statistics don't work for me